your books reviewed this week you must
be so excited more like terrified
mashiko kagutani
she's the times book critic oh i thought
you were suggesting an appetizer she's
brilliant and she's really tough and
impossible to pronounce sex and the city
star willie garson died at the age of 57
from a private battle with cancer back
in september in the middle of filming
the show's revival and just like that
but really what's missing is willie
garson that's the person that's missing
so i think that's where
the question should be asked what kind
of absence is that well i just think we
should focus on the people that have an
absence that is an undoing rather than a
creative decision that was
you know calm and thoughtful this was a
person that was lost um far too soon
who was going to play a significant role
and that's the kind of
space you can't fill and on thursday's
episode of the sex in the city sequel
series willie's character stanford's
sudden absence is explained so this is
your official spoiler warning if you
haven't watched yet sarah jessica
parker's carrie bradshaw returns to her
old apartment and finds a handwritten
letter on stanford stationery
[Music]
carrie then calls over stanford's
husband anthony marantino played by
mario cantone
you're smoking
stanford's in japan
that's ashley the 17 year old long
island tick tock star he manages she's
huge in asia
she asked him to go on tour with her
well fine good sayonara but why the
dramatic note
by the time you read this i'll be in
tokyo i mean
who is he the lost bronte sister he said
he couldn't bring himself to tell you he
was leaving face to face after big died
right and a note is so much more
compassionate oh you know stanny he
hates to disappoint people
in person that comment could be a nod to
the cast's reality as willie reportedly
did not disclose his cancer diagnosis to
his co-stars until his final days but
back to stanford's on-screen send-off
anthony proceeds to tell carrie he also
received a note i got a letter too he
wants a divorce
i don't get it
we were so happy this seems like it
could be the last time fans hear from
stanford on the show's 10-episode run at
the series premiere event mario revealed
to et that anthony and stanford's story
was rewritten after garson's death i am
thrilled to be here and i'm sad too
because i miss willy i'm really sad
about this so it's a weird thing you
know but we're doing this for him you
know this is for him and i i'm just
happy we made it through we all kind of
huddled together
and and held on to each other and we did
it how was your role as anthony impacted
the loss of global it was you know it
things had to be rewritten and what
they're going to see tonight is the
first two and you see our our marriage
our turbulent yet
clingy
loving
argumentative marriage you just left
we're not in the same place i told you i
wasn't waiting what kind of person just
leaves steve would you ever just leave
miranda what fortunately you're not
gonna get to see what it was gonna be
which i just i think about this every
minute of every day but what michael
patrick king did was brilliant he knows
what he's doing
there were quick rewrites and we did
them it's a mixed bag believe me how
lucky you were to have them for the time
that you did and
you would have never known right he was
in incredible spirits and hilarious and
brilliant he's so alive in the first
three episodes and just like that
episode four ends with a tribute screen
to willy with the message quote in
memory of a beloved friend there's also
this quote from willy himself be kind to
each other always